This is one of those moments
you got to ask yourself,
what do I want?
the world and built for guys like us.
You have seen what I can do
This
This is one of those moments
you got to ask yourself,
what kind of life do I want
the world and build for guys like us?
That's
why we've got to take whatever we decide is on us.
My focus is right hand.
Try to push me out.
Why are
you've seeing what I can do
if you step out of line?
Even once I got you like a goddamn fish.
You imagine the people say in my name in the streets.
After I'm gone
and it means something
to know came and it got them.
Welcome back everyone
It's Charlie
HBO and Max just dropped a bunch of new trailers
in the last week
because the Brazil Comic-Con CCXP,
and we got some more footage of that.
That man series is coming to HBO
based on Colin Farrell's
penguin from the events of Matt Reeves
and Robert Pattinson's Batman movies.
We learned about some of the plots,
some of the big Batman villains, other major characters
that will show up during the episodes
and how it sets up the Batman two movie.
So we'll break it all down.
If you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get all the episodes
I know, there's a bit of a question
about how all of these are going to work because
James Gunn just rebooted the DCU and they have
all that stuff that's going to be connected
and then you have all the Elseworlds stuff like,
this is the giant chart of all of the upcoming movies
and TV series in where it fits like Elseworlds
versus DCU versus all the other stuff.
there's a lot of stuff.
They announce only a couple things
coming during 2020 for very few DC series.
Most of the big DC stuff
won't be so like 2025 and beyond.
they confirmed all the Penguin episodes
will start releasing late 2024,
which typically means around the fall unless they see
something different in the next couple of months.
Matt Reeves already revealed
that Episode one is meant to begin about a week
after the ending of the Batman movie, with the city
still mostly underwater from the Riddler's attack.
like here.
At the end of the movie,
you saw him standing in Falcone's office
looking out over the wreckage of the city
like all this damage.
That's basically where the series begins.
The Riddler just got thrown in Arkham Asylum.
The Joker's there with him.
There's all that stuff going on in the background, too.
They're not meant to be, like,
really huge characters during the Penguin.
But all that stuff is happening
during the events of the episodes.
and they basically begin the series with the Penguin
trying to seize Carmine Falcone's
criminal empire
as his own before the other New York City mob.
Boss's surviving members of Falcone's own family
try to take it first.
Power abhors a vacuum
in Gotham City, in Falcone was meant to be
like the top mob boss
at the time of his fall during the movie.
So it's basically a mad dash for power
right from the start.
Matt Reeves called it Penguin's Scarface
moment, his rise to power as a crime boss in his own
right up to this point, he's just been one of Carmine
Falcone's lieutenants, one of the underboss. Is
that's why there's all that dialog in the trailer
from the penguin,
talking about seizing his moment, deciding
what kind of person he wants to be.
the way that Matt Reeves is pitching it,
it sounds like one of the chief antagonists,
if not the chief antagonist,
will be the other major crime boss in New York City,
Sal Maroni, He'll be played by Clancy Brown.
If you remember,
Maroni was framed by Falcone for the drops
the Gotham City renewal plot
before the events of the first movie began.
And he's been in prison for a while for that.
So he's seeking revenge against the former
Falcone crime family.
Even though Falcone is dead,
like he still wants his revenge.
And seeking to reclaim his lost territory in power
that Falcone absorbed after he went into prison
during the events of the first movie,
they also canonize that Sal Maroni
was actually the person responsible
for the creation of that drops drug
that had become an epidemic in the city.
During the events of the first movie,
there were a bunch of references to the drops,
but they never really resolved that plot,
probably because Maroni is a huge character
during the Penguin episodes.
Matt Reeves is always intended on paying that off
during the series.
if you didn't catch it during the first movie, too.
They also explain
Maroni had a lot of history with Thomas Wayne.
He was the one that was responsible for hiring Thomas
Eliot, the reporter, to dig up dirt on Martha
Wayne being in the Arkham State mental Hospital
when he was running for mayor of Gotham City.
that set up that whole hush plot
like big hush Easter egg from the Batman comics
Carmine Falcone having the reporter killed,
then using that event to blackmail Thomas Wayne,
eventually allowing the mob bosses of Gotham
to take over the Gotham City Renewal Fund,
using it to launder their money,
setting up everything that's going on in present day.
Originally Maroni hire
the reporter Thomas Eliot, hoping to gain
some traction, some leverage against Thomas Wayne,
knowing that he might become mayor.
Like if he becomes mayor and I have some dirt on him
I can use to blackmail him to do whatever I want,
even though his plans eventually failed,
he joined Falcone,
the other mob bosses,
when they took over the Gotham City Renewal Fund.
It was taking an equal share of the money
from that part of the idea,
though, is that he started to become more powerful,
especially when he created the drops in.
Falcone wanted to basically get rid of him
by having him thrown in prison,
basically informing on him to Pete Savage,
the police commissioner at the time, and Gil Colson,
the corrupt district attorney,
to have him thrown in prison.
Then he basically took over Maloney's
former territory in the city.
so part of the idea you have to remember
is that Maroni probably wound up getting released
from prison after Gil Colson and Pete Savage's
corruption was discovered.
it would have basically voided
any arrests in major convictions that they made.
So a bunch of criminals
would be getting released from prison, not just.
MARONI look at Clancy Brown like,
is it not time to pay the piper?
He is going to wreck a bunch of people
during the series.
that's one of the major threads.
The Penguin has to deal with during the series.
there's also everything
that's going on with Robert Pattinson's Batman.
Remember, he actually worked with Penguin.
The penguin actually helped him.
So he kind of owes him
a solid will probably get at least a minor
cameo as Bruce Wayne and or Batman
just to explain what he's doing in these weeks
after the end of the first movie,
before the events of the Batman
to pick up there, a couple new characters
that they show in the footage here, like Michael Kelly,
most of you recognize from somewhere.
He's in a bunch of big stuff.
He's playing.
John Beatty, one of Falcone's
other former underboss, is just like the penguin
who's also probably vying with the penguin
to try and take over that former empire.
one of the other biggest characters is going to be
Falcone's daughter Sophia, played by Cristin Milioti.
She's actually supposed to be Penguin's
main love interest during the series.
So I'm expecting kind of a twist with her character.
Like they set her up as like a traditional
love interest who probably grew up with everybody
thinking that she didn't want to have anything to do
with Falcone's crime family or that side of his life.
like literally prediction
they'll reveal that she's actually super smart
and there's a bit of play back and forth
between her and Penguin like she's nice
she's going to roll over
and let him completely take over her father's empire.
She might try to take over herself,
there's usually the kind of twist
you see with characters like that, like,
she's not a damsel in distress.
She's actually a pretty big bad ass Falcone
son, Alberto
and his widow are also part of the series,
also play vying for control of the family, too.
Like Penguin getting hauled in by a couple of men
here to talk to this person.
this might be Falcone's widow trying to rake him over
the coals about what happened to Falcone.
The kid in the trailer that's helping the penguin load
the body into the back of the car.
Very classic mob story.
Sopranos meets the Batman.
He's supposed to be a random teenager.
The penguin befriends like he finds him on the streets,
befriends him, and then turns him into his driver.
But generally.
Most of the trailer footage that we've seen so far
is just giving us vibes for the series.
Like, we don't see a ton of the actual story.
We'll probably get a trailer in the next couple
of months with more actual footage from the series.
I've written a couple videos
about the Batman two movies,
so I'll link them down to the description below.
We learned about some of the characters,
some of the plot that Matt Reeves has talked about,
most of those are rumors right now.
Like there's rumors that Robin is actually going
to show up at some point during the series.
Timothy Shalom
even talked about becoming a version of Robin,
even though I think he's a little too old relative
to Robert Pattinson's age
during the events of the Batman two,
like he's still in his twenties, any version of Dick
Grayson, Robin would have to be like way, way
younger than Timothy Salame.
when they started releasing footage of the first movie,
a lot of people actually thought that it was this kid
just because of the way that Robert Pattinson's
Batman was staring at him at the funeral here.
But remember, that was meant to be the mayor's son.
So it wasn't a version of Dick Grayson.
it was just meant to be a scene where he sees
this little kid and sees himself in the kid, like,
this same kind of thing happened to me when I was
a little kid and my parents were killed in Crime Alley.
the only other thing we know that Matt Reeves
is working on with the Batman universe
is that Arkham Show.
And I think that that's what they'll pick up.
A lot of the Riddler, the Joker storyline
in a lot of other Batman Rogues Gallery of Villains.
they didn't say when that's going to release.
What they might do, though, is that they don't do
the Penguin Season two is
they'll try to release that Arkham show
like the year after the Batman two comes out.
So they might do it like the Marvel Disney Plus series,
where there aren't a lot of season twos
or they could always swerve on that
because it sounds like Marvel's also swerving on that
and now doing things more like regular TV series
where they do get multiple seasons.
so instead of doing a bunch of different Batman
TV series, they could just wind up doing season two,
season three of The Penguin,
and and just doing all those other spin off plots.
On the Penguin series.
James Gunn
also confirmed that he is doing Peacemaker Season two,
but that's actually going to be set inside his DCU,
like all the connected stuff
as opposed to the Batman stuff,
which is off in its own little universe.
Peacemaker won't come back till after he releases
Superman Legacy in 2025, which is also the same year
that the Batman two is coming out.
It's going to be a big year for DC in 2025.
my only hope for the Peacemaker series right now
is they actually use them as sort of like the psycho
pirate of the DC Universe, like James Gunn's New DCU,
and he's like the only character
who remembers the DC EU
in the previous version of the Justice League.
Like everything that came before,
so because his whole thing is these is crazy conspiracy
nut always yelling about crazy conspiracy theories
is that during the events of the series he goes on
and on about this big reboot but nobody believes him
because he does sound so crazy all the time.
like he winds up seeing some footage of Superman
in the new version of Batman.
And eventually it is like,
wait a minute, that's not Batman, that's not Superman.
What happened to them?
How come you guys don't realize things have changed?
The universe has been rebooted.
How come nobody's talking about it?
There's a bunch of stuff coming up.
There are a couple other big trailers that released
recently, so I'll try to do videos for everything.
But if you have any questions about what's going on
in the Batman universe with those movies
and the other DC movies,
just write them in the comments below.
We do have Aquaman two coming up,
but that's sort of like the very last
DCU movie,
so that's not connected to any of the Batman stuff
I'll do my regular Post-Credits scene videos, Easter
egg videos for the Aquaman movie.
When it does wind up coming out, everyone
click here for that brand new Deadpool 3 teaser
and click here for my brand new House
of the Dragon Season two trailer video and Easter Eggs.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!